have enough on 5 27 on your Wednesday
morning what's driving you crazy well
there are only a few more weeks left in
the current school year but a bus driver
says some of us are driving him crazy
Gene writes I'm overwhelmed by how many
drivers ignore the stop arms and red
lights when loading or unloading
students it's astounding how many
drivers are oblivious to these safety
features that are mandatory striving me
crazy Gene here are a couple of helpful
tips from the Minnesota State Police the
driver of a vehicle approaching a school
bus displaying flashing red lights with
the stop arm extended must stop at least
20 feet away from the bus even if the
two-lane roadway has a center turn lane
vehicles in all lanes are required to
stop a four-lane roadway without median
separation requires all vehicles
traveling in both directions to stop
I hope this helps because maybe some
people are confused Gene thanks for
riding in buckle up drive carefully and
please put on that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com